[Music]
covering a half-acre with hanging
flowers the oldest-known wisteria in
japan is the centerpiece of this
brilliantly pastel colored flower park
[Music]
located in toh cheeky japan just over an
hour train ride from tokyo is a chicago
flower park the park spans 23 acres and
is home to more than 350 mysterious and
other flowers the colors vary depending
on the flowering season from pinks and
purples to yellows and whites some
features of the park include the
wisteria tunnel and floating gardens but
the pride and joy of a Chicago flower
park is the great miracle wisteria the
140 year old sprawling tree is located
in a place of pride right in the center
of the park after nightfall the site is
lit up so these draping flowers can be
seen at all hours
the vivid yellow wisteria begins
blooming at the start of May and is the
only one of its kind in Japan the park
is a year-round attraction with seasonal
plants that creates an ever-changing
sense of magnificence as nature puts on
a show
some people who come to this house it
looks like something out of a romantic
magical fairytale but this romantic
magical fairytale really is our home
I'm jasmine I'm Simon and we live out in
the pasola Hills in West Wales we're
part of a wide community that spreads
over the whole region and the local area
of people learning to read softly on the
earth when we decide to settle down make
permanent home it would seem fairly
clear to us we much prefer to be in the
countryside and I did like the sort of
magical element of you know the idea of
faeries and we built a small simple
modest house out of the things that were
around us out of the things that we
could easily get from waste and from the
natural world rather than going and
buying things this is where we store our
firewood to keep us warm through the
winter it took us about two months so
we've used stones mud clay wood we
brought in some straw bales news quite a
lot of those and it cost us around about
two or three thousand pounds in the big
house and one was finishing it to a very
high standard so that we'll have a lot
of longevity will last a long time
generations and we are using recycled
materials natural materials or things
that we've grown available from this
piece of land this is my greenhouse you
put the food in relationship to the
house and to the water and to the
landscape and instantly income the
fellows the birds and the insects our
dirty water can feed the plants our need
for shelter can give nice shelter for
other animals to come and live and we
really can live in a way which is
sympathetic to the rest of what's going
on in nature in my workshop my commute
to work goes a bit like this out of the
front door
dodging between the flowers and maybe
picking a few berries off the bush on
the way part of Phillips neck until I
get to my workshop
at the end of every day I could sit back
and see the thing that we've made and
know where the people would have come
from I mean first night in a house that
you've made with your own friends and
with your own hands in exactly the way
you want it to be is an absolutely
magical
[Music]
rising out of the Tuscan hills are some
colorful and unusual figures inspired by
tarot cards the tarot park is located in
Tuscany a few hours outside of Rome the
park took 20 years to complete and
includes 22 figures from the tarot deck
there's a Sphinx that leads to a golden
skeleton riding a blue horse over green
sea this represents death the hanged man
can be found inside one of the sparkling
grottoes suspended from the ceiling and
one of the most bizarre figures is the
Oracle which is a hollow-eyed figure
surrounded and covered by snakes
the eccentric artist who created this
garden was Niki de Saint full in the
early 1950s
Mickey was committed to an asylum and
believes it was art that eventually
healed her she wanted to create a place
that would have the same healing effect
on those who visited the park opened in
1998 just four years before Nikki's
death in her own words she dreamt of
building a garden that would be a
dialogue between sculpture and nature a
place to dream it
[Music]
Lima longjin is a curious place very
curious and it all comes from the mind
of a clown in Azores lava
yo yo da do da glove de la mesilla
circa theater jelenia it was his shame
slava is an avant-garde performance
artist and one of the most recognizable
clowns in the world he grew up in
communist Russia and spent his youth
idolizing Charlie Chaplin Slava
revolutionized the art of clowning
moving it out of the circus and onto the
stage the yellow rabbit exactly yellow
field assassin alights academia knockoff
could she just you made resiliency
rhythm solid not smoke receiver play
active isomer Taniya muy Phoenix to Sam
oppressed or Zima picnic the Milan John
is lavas creative space where he and his
family and his Academy of fools host
open events run workshops and rehearsals
all in his surreal Wonderland a pillow
here oblivion ability as a minute or two
scary gee mr. gimmick watching come
forth now vermin itch yeah you belong to
Orchestra in Chimbote shiva kamini ax
symbols mean
yama with halitosis e navasana store
radial sabaki virus a beard illness your
shoddy royally booth would clone Rasta
targeted virus doses the ostrich of
attention items reasonably whistling
quiet results my advice would be
[Music]
[Music]
for a castle straight out of a fairy
tale look no further than the alcázar of
Segovia located in central Spain the
alcázar of Segovia is one of the
country's most visited and distinctive
landmarks built in the 12th century the
Alcazar has served many functions over
the years a fortress a royal palace a
state prison an Artillery College and
most recently a museum and military
archive however its most famous function
could arguably be that it served as an
inspiration and some of the most iconic
Disney films the similarities between
Segovia and Cinderella can be found in
the building's brick facade turrets and
location perched high above the
neighbouring countryside Walt Disney
also went on to reproduce Segovia as the
Queen's castle and Snow White with it
appearing in the film and it's almost
exact form if you can make it up more
than a hundred and fifty stairs to the
top of the tower you will be rewarded
with stunning views fit for a queen
[Music]
[Music]
swordmaking has always been an esoteric
endeavored there's never been a great
number of people doing it you have this
transformation of raw material the
alteration of nature and in the end you
get something that just exudes power
[Music]
this is Valyrian steel my father's sword
the ancient swords on Game of Thrones
forged with Valyrian steel were stronger
and lighter than any other weapon no one
knows how they were made in the real
world over a thousand years ago in
Viking lands there was also a series of
special swords with mysterious origins
and a blacksmith in Wisconsin tried to
make one this is an old Bert sword from
about 850 to maybe early 1200s in viking
controlled lands you had a sword that
had a name inlay called wolf bert which
roughly translates to wolf tooth or wolf
bear it's a word of power there are only
350 known ulfberht swords forged with
the quality of Steel that didn't emerge
in Europe for another thousand years no
one knows exactly how they were made I
think I've come fairly close or at least
a pretty good rendition of how they made
those blades steel is a pretty special
material we know a great deal about it
and we know almost nothing about it so
what the old Bert you have a mythical
steel mirrored in the game of thrones
where you have this deal that no one's
able to reproduce that black Valyrian
steel sword making technology still
holds a bit of alchemy a bit of
mysticism in it we want to believe that
there's something that we can't
understand there's still mysteries in
steel